la connaissance à partager la planète à
protéger c'est le thème de la
candidature française pour l'exposition
universelle de 2025 un projet porté sur
le site de paris saclay le village
global serait installé sur le campus
composé de 65 mille étudiants et 15
mille chercheurs avec ce globe terrestre
comme coeur de l'exposition universelle
le visiteur sera appelé à faire vraiment
le tour du monde c'est à parcourir le
globe découvrir le monde et découvrir
également tous les enjeux de la planète
le projet d'aménagement de toute cette
zone correspond très bien à ce
croisement entre la science le savoir le
progrès d'un côté et puis de l'autre
côté l'environnement la planète dont
nous savons qu'elle est pas mal en
danger 40 millions de visiteurs attendus
pour organiser cet événement expo france
2025 table sur un budget de 3 5
milliards d'euros financé en partie par
des entreprises pour les riverains les
avis sont mitigés montrez au monde de
savoir faire français toute l'innovation
tu peux être rassemblées en un point
donc je pense que oui c'est une occasion
unique de briller je vois ces photos ça
me fait peur et ça ne donne pas du tout
envie ça paraît sympa race sauf que je
vois l'impact
géographique en surface sur un endroit
qui qui a été autrefois très agricole
avec des chants des bois etc et je me
dis que c'est l'occasion de finir de le
détruire engagé dans la campagne michel
bournat président de la communauté
d'agglomération de paris saclay se veut
rassurant par rapport aux inquiétudes et
aux interrogations des habitants sur le
fait que pendant six mois ci à 40
millions de visiteurs
territoire risquent d'être un petit peu
surchargé c'est vrai c'est réel mais est
ce que c'est
utile ou pas pour notre territoire moi
je dis oui le comité expo france 2025 va
se lancer dans la campagne
internationale pour tenter de convaincre
les cent soixante dix états membres le
vote final pour l'attribution de
l'exposition universelle de 2025 aura
lieu en novembre 2018